Laurent mercure je me tourne vers vous
pour parler avec vous des grands projets
de l'année 2023 à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
je le rappelle vous êtes le maire de la
commune alors en ce début d'année on a
commencé à en parler tout à l'heure
revient souvent un mot dans la bouche de
tout le monde c'est celui de la sobriété
énergétique vous avez fait le choix de
faire des vœux en vidéo à Montigny
justement pour vous conformer à cette
sobriété énergétique et ne pas forcément
organiser de de cérémonie de vœux il y a
aussi un plan sobriété qui a été adopté
à Montigny fin 2022 que prévoit-il et
qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez de faire en
2023 sur cette thématique alors en fait
on a profité de la situation de la crise
énergétique pour
se questionner sur des des solutions qui
pourraient trouver à la fois dans le
très court terme mais aussi sur le long
terme parce que c'est la vertu des
crises c'est qu'elle pousse à un
changement plus rapide en général on
voit le télétravail et la
visioconférence avec la covid et là avec
ce qui se passe actuellement avec la
crise éner en fait on serait interroge
sur toutes nos pratiques sur les usages
de nos bâtiments donc les mesures
rapides qui ont été faites ça a été de
baisser la température dans les
équipements de fermer pendant un mois le
centre aquatique puisque c'est
l'équipement qui consomme le plus
d'énergie sur le sur le territoire de
Montigny ça a été aussi de regarder avec
toutes les associations et d'ailleurs
nous avions une réunion samedi matin
avec toutes nos associations culturelles
pour regarder ensemble l'utilisation des
locaux voir comment optimiser les
espaces de façon à pouvoir générer des
économies et un autre point important
qui sera présenté dans le budget qui
sera voté le mois prochain pour la ville
c'est aussi un emprunt que nous faisons
auprès de la banque des territoires qui
est un emprunt spécifique destiné à
pouvoir remplacer très rapidement tous
les luminaires que l'on peut avoir sur
nos équipements on a 70 équipements sur
la ville donc remplacer tous les
luminaires par des leds je te remets
installer des robinets thermostatiques
partout il en manquerait changer les
vieux radettes les grille-pains comme on
dit par des radiateurs plus performants
et ça vraiment ça c'est le très court
terme et puis derrière encore une fois
c'est réfléchir à tous nos usages mais
ça nous le faisons de manière collective
et concertée avec les associations qui
d'ailleurs sont très forces de
proposition dans ce domaine là donc
c'est vraiment un débat très intéressant
qu'on peut mener sur le sujet on va
avoir les grands dossiers de 2023 qui va
voir le jour prochainement on a
l'habitude à descendu on avait
l'habitude d'aller fouler les cours de
ce club de sport c'est le club le
village qui va réouvrir et qui a
bénéficié en plus d'une rénovation
thermique et aussi de nouvelles
disciplines qui pourront être pratiquées
au sein de ce club c'est ça alors sur la
réhabilitation thermique pour faire un
peu la suite du sujet que nous évoquons
là c'est vrai qu'on est dans une
continuité sur ce mandat puisqu'on a
déjà réhabilité deux écoles sur le
quartier des prés ainsi que la maison de
quartier Malraux et donc désormais c'est
le club le village on espère une
économie d'énergie de 60% sur
l'équipement et derrière un bâtiment qui
dans son fonctionnement c'est un
bâtiment qui datait des années 80 a été
complètement revu donc un confort pour
les usagers complètement différents un
lieu d'accueil beaucoup plus sympathique
et une nouvelle discipline nous avons
gardé le tennis nous avons gardé le
squash nous gardons le badminton mais
nous offrons désormais du foot en salle
du futsal comme on dit et nous proposer
aussi du padel donc cette activité de
tennis sur des petites terrains voilà
des activités nouvelles qui vont venir
s'ajouter à ce que propose la ville de
Montigny désormais nous restons dans les
équipements rénovés ou même nouveau
alors en 2023 il y a la rénovation
thermique de la crèche Comtesse de Ségur
dans le quartier de Saint-Quentin il y
aura même la construction d'une nouvelle
crèche dans le quartier de la Sourderie
alors je vais commencer par la nouvelle
crèche effectivement qui vient à la
place de l'ancienne école sa main sur
laquelle donc que nous avons rasé il y a
quelques années sur laquelle nous avons
fait un programme de logement et ce
nouvel équipement destiné à la petite
enfance qui lui aussi thermiquement sera
évidemment
extrêmement intéressant mais qui
présente des espaces qui sont très très
bien pensés pour accueillir nos enfants
donc c'est pour nous une capacité
d'accueil de 50 enfants qui qui se crée
sur la ville avec donc des des mauvaise
qualitatif des espaces extérieurs aussi
pour les enfants donc à partir de la
rentrée prochaine de septembre prochain
nous aurons un nouveau lieu d'accueil
pour la petite enfance à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux donc ça c'est
pour la nouvelle crèche
de Ségur qui elle est une crèche
historique de la ville de Montigny situé
dans le quartier Saint-Quentin pas très
loin d'ici cette crèche là elle était
effectivement thermiquement
très dépassé et puis fatigué donc nous
avons décidé de la reprendre
complètement et de de la transformer
pour avoir une crèche qui réponde elle
aussi à toutes les nouvelles normes en
matière d'énergie et non seulement nous
réhabilitons complètement la crèche mais
nous renaturons la cour de cette crèche
qui était entièrement bitumée jusque là
et qui demain proposera de la végétation
et des espaces beaucoup plus verts que
ce que nous avions jusqu'à aujourd'hui
dans les cartons également à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il y a aussi
cette réhabilitation du centre sportif
Pierre de Coubertin le centre loisir de
loisirs du Manet est-ce qu'il y aura du
concret cette année sur ce qui va alors
sur le sur Coubertin oui c'est déjà va
commencer puisque nous avons nous sommes
en train de de sélectionner le cabinet
d'architecte qui nous accompagnera sur
cette réhabilitation et puis il faut
bien ça savoir se rappeler que sur cette
réhabilitation nous sommes à la fois sur
les espaces intérieurs mais aussi sur
les expats extérieurs c'est à dire qu'on
va refaire le terrain de foot
synthétique on va refaire la piste on va
proposer là aussi de nouvelles activités
avec du sport à outdoor du street
workout s'appelle comme ça et puis sur
l'intérieur de l'équipement
effectivement là on va être plutôt dans
la phase administrative et tout le
travail préparatoire avant ses grands
travaux qui arriveront en 2024 ou 2025
pour le centre de loisirs du Monet
centre de loisirs du Manet là nous cette
année ça sera la phase administrative
c'est pareil tout le travail à la fois
pour préparer ce dossier puis en même
temps toute la recherche des subventions
parce que nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
plus que jamais avec la situation
économique de pouvoir chercher des
subventions donc c'est tout le travail
auquel nous allons nous atteler cette
année en 2023 sera aussi l'année du
lancement de grands travaux à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux avec
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
les travaux de l'hypercentre autrement
dit tout le quartier autour de la gare
et du théâtre de Saint-Quentin avec donc
le début des travaux prévus cette année
en tout cas le début du chantier c'est
cette année oui alors là c'est un
aboutissement de toute cette phase
administrative dont je parlais pour les
dossiers précédents et bien nous
arrivons au bout cette fois-ci pour
l'hyper centre rappelez-vous on a
commencé en 2019 avec la concertation
des habitants du quartier et là
aujourd'hui nous pouvons prévoir un
démarrage des travaux en fin d'année
sachant que ça commencera un peu plus
tôt puisque nous avons déjà la
démolition de l'immeuble que l'on
appelle l'anneau rouge que l'on a vu
voilà autour de la place de la gare avec
toute la reprise de la place et
l'ouverture de celle-ci sur sur la ville
et puis ensuite évidemment on a l'avenue
du centre qui va être refaite dans un
premier temps avec la place Pompidou
puis nous referons tout le long du canal
et le bassin du quai Truffaut donc juste
à côté de la médiathèque donc là on est
sur un chantier qui va durer plusieurs
années on va faire un certain nombre de
réunions avec les habitants pour leur
expliquer un petit peu comment tout cela
va se passer parce qu'effectivement
comme nous sommes en centre-ville ça va
perturber un petit peu les choses mais
on comprend bien aujourd'hui l'enjeu que
ça peut représenter à la fois pour la
ville de Montigny mais aussi pour
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et pour le
département qui d'ailleurs va être très
présent à nos côtés financièrement sur
cette opération parce que c'est un enjeu
majeur pour le département des Yvelines
également donc ça c'est une véritable
satisfaction effectivement de voir ce
sujet aboutir et d'aboutir de cette
façon la thématique du handicap aussi
est centrale à Montigny-le-Bretonneux il
y a une semaine du handicap chaque année
qui est l'un des rendez-vous phares de
l'année il y a la Fondation aussi Anne
De Gaulle qui va ouvrir une structure
d'accueil pour les personnes en
situation de handicap oui absolument ça
c'était un souhait très fort que nous
portions nous venons comme vous l'avez
dit une politique très active sur le la
thématique du handicap mais nous
n'avions pas de structure d'accueil pour
personne en situation de handicap sur la
ville j'ai su en tout début de mandat de
la fondation de Gaulle je cherchais un
lieu d'accueil pour sa structure et donc
j'ai proposé qu'il puisse venir sur
Montigny et donc les travaux vont
démarrer cette année et ce qui est
vraiment très intéressant là-dedans
c'est que il y a une démarche au niveau
de la Fondation Anne De Gaulle
aujourd'hui complètement nouvelle sur la
prise en charge de ces personnes qui
sont des personnes déficientes
intellectuelles et qu'il s'agit de
complètement enfin d'intégrer au mieux à
la cité et donc ils vont créer un Living
Lab en plus du lieu d'accueil un lieu de
recherche pour justement voir comment
permettre aux personnes en situation de
handicap d'accéder à la citoyenneté et
vivre je leur ai proposé s'il y a un
lieu où se joue la citoyenneté dans une
ville c'est bien la mairie donc on y a
un partenariat entre nous pour de façon
à pouvoir travailler sur ce sujet là et
voir comment mieux intégrer encore ces
personnes dans l'avenir de grandes fêtes
à venir aussi pour la ville avant les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques en 2024
il y aura le 23 juillet 2023 à cocher
sur le calendrier puisque mon team
Bretonneux sera la ville départ de la
dernière étape du Tour de France donc
21ème et dernière étape de l'édition
2023 qui s'élancera du vélo Drôme
direction les Champs-Élysées on imagine
une exposition très très importante pour
la ville avec ce rendez-vous très suivi
et bien oui c'est une très très belle
surprise et là-dessus je tiens à
remercier
à se de nous avoir choisi et puis
évidemment le président du conseil
départemental pierre Bédié qui qui lui
aussi a pesé de tout son poids pour que
les choses puissent se faire de cette
manière
ça préfigure les Jeux Olympiques qui
arriveront en 2024 donc un grand
événement sportif festif extrêmement
populaire qui qui démarrera qui débutera
pour sa dernière étape sur Montigny
évidemment oui c'est une façon de donner
à voir le territoire et ça c'est une
très très belle une très bonne nouvelle
et ça va mettre en lumière ce site
olympique le vélo de route nationale sa
piste de BMX aussi est-ce que c'est un
rendez-vous qui se prépare déjà en 2023
c'est Jeux Olympiques même si c'est
l'année prochaine en 2010 bien sûr et
nous les préparons déjà depuis un
certain temps on a commencé avec la
recherche des bénévoles nous avons mis
en place aussi tout un programme
éviter d'animation il y a des choses qui
se sont déroulées au Vélodrome par
exemple mais nous faisons aussi chaque
année des découvertes de sport au sein
des écoles à Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
puis nous avons associé là aussi toutes
nos associations pour voir quels
événements nous pourrions mettre en
place pour sensibiliser la population
parce qu'évidemment pour que ce soit un
beau rendez-vous il faut que la
population se sente associée concernée
par cet événement et que nous n'ayons
pas que les gens qui viendront assister
aux épreuves sur le territoire tout
dernière chose si on reste dans ce
secteur on va dire du vélo Drôme parmi
les autres grands projets il y aura le
lancement 2023 d'études pour la
réalisation d'une passerelle piéton
cycliste qui permettra d'accéder à l'île
de loisirs de Saint-Quentin on est dans
le cas du RER vélo là donc c'est avec la
région Île-de-France et 50 ans en
Yvelines nous aurons ce vieux rêve que
nous avions avec mon prédécesseur Michel
logier il y a quelques années de pouvoir
créer une passerelle qui permette
d'accéder pour les piétons et les
cyclistes à l'île de loisirs au-dessus
de l'autoroute et à l'époque nous étions
heurtés à des coûts absolument
prohibitifs et bien aujourd'hui grâce à
ce plan vélo développé avec la région
nous avons la possibilité de mettre en
place cette passerelle et donc demain
nous aurons une liaison supplémentaire
pour aller vers l'île de loisirs
complètement protégé donc énormément de
projets sur Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
évidemment en tant que mère j'en suis
absolument ravi parce que le nous avons
un mandat un peu particulier là je parle
pour tous les maires qui ont débuté en
2020 entre la crise sanitaire et
aujourd'hui la crise de l'énergie et
pour autant sur Montigny nous arrivons à
avoir des projets enthousiasmants et qui
vont redonner encore de la dynamique
supplémentaire au territoire et pour
terminer cet entretien on passe à
l'interview express
[Musique]
Laura Mercier je vais vous poser cinq
questions cinq questions qui nécessitent
des réponses courtes oui un nom un pour
ou contre parfois quelques explications
je vais vous demander de faire vos
explications sur 20 et 30 secondes ce
sera la seule exigence et on posera la
question à l'ensemble des maires 50 en
Yvelines qui vont venir en plateau sur
ce mois de janvier est-ce qu'en 2023
vous augmenterez les impôts locaux dans
votre commune non si elle est sur la
circulation certaines communes ont opté
pour la limitation à 30 km/h ce que vous
vous êtes pour ou contre une telle idée
nous l'avons déjà mis en place dans un
certain nombre de résidences oui depuis
longtemps donc peut-être une étendre à
Montigny ou rester travaillant là-dessus
avec les conseils de quartier oui mais
il faut qu'on fasse attention chaque
voie en fonction de son dimensionnement
et de son utilité doit avoir une vitesse
adaptée et donc on regarde ça il s'agit
pas de prendre une décision comme ça
grossir pour l'ensemble de la ville mais
bien d'être sur des choses qui répondent
aux besoins que l'on peut avoir de
circulation sur le territoire certaines
communes ont fait le choix du bio pour
leur cantine est-ce que vous êtes pour
ou contre l'obligation du Bio dans les
cantines ou peut-être pour une
incitation des communes
je pense que de toute façon nous allons
petit à petit progressivement vers de
plus en plus de bio d'ailleurs c'est ce
que nous avons fait dans le cas de notre
nouveau marché de restauration scolaire
ça fait partie des sujets que l'on
travaille aussi avec l'agglomération
j'avais demandé en tout début de mandat
qui a un travail commun pour que l'on
voit comment au niveau de des filières
d'approvisionnement alimentaire on
puisse mettre en place quelque chose au
niveau de cuisine centrale à l'échelle
de 50 ans en Yvelines donc nous y allons
et c'est une bonne chose je crois est-ce
que au cours de votre mandat vous avez
été vous avez eu l'impression d'être
comment dire d'être menacé physiquement
non jamais jamais jamais parce que
beaucoup de mer en quelques mères ont
été victimes effectivement d'agression
ou de menaces et enfin une dernière
question est-ce que vous êtes un maire
heureux ah oui complètement pleinement
merci Laurent mercière pour ces réponses
courtes vous allez jouer le jeu en tout
cas ce soir je rappelle que vous êtes le
maire de Montigny-le-Bretonneux très
bonne année 2023 dans votre commune
merci à vous et très bonne année à
toutes et à tous